Today Republic Act too.
I mean,
what I want to do is continue with the,
uh,
account of the various figures,
various persons who,
uh,
populate,
who inhabit this dialogue and who they are,
what they represent,
and how they contribute to the argument and the,
and the structure of the work.
Uh,
as a whole,
last time,
and I won't repeat this last time,
you'll remember,
we,
we talked briefly at the end of class about capitalists and Socrates,
uh,
treatment of capitalists,
the embodiment of convention,
uh,
the embodiment of,
of Athenian opinion and the way in which Socrates,
Socrates,
as it were,
uh,
Chase's,
a capitalist out of the dialogue,
out of the,
out of the conversation.
We never hear from him again.
And,
uh,
the speakers are able presumably to pursue the audacious arguments,
that will,
will appear in the rest of the book without the oversight of the,
uh,
the head of the household,
the embodiment of conventional opinion.
And Socrates next pursues this discussion with,
uh,
the son of capitalists,
Palo Marcus,
the man who first approached,
uh,
had a,
had a Socrates approached on,
on the Pi Radius.
Paula Marcus is described as the air of the argument as well as the,
to be sure the air of the family Fortune Paula Marcus is what the Greeks would
call a gentleman that has to say he's a person willing to stand up for and
defend his family and friends.
I don't mean necessarily by a gentleman,
somebody who holds the door for others or so on,
but somebody who stands up for his family and friends,
uh,
in the way that he does,
unlike his father.
However,
Paula Marcus shows himself concerned not just with the needs of the body as
capitalists represented.
Paula Marcus is concerned to defend the honor and safety of the Polis.
He accepts the view,
uh,
that justice is giving to each what is owed,
but he interpreted this to mean the justice means doing good to your friends and
harm to your enemies.
Justice we might say is a kind of loyalty.
It is a kind of loyalty that we feel to members of a family,
to members of our team,
to member,
to fellow students of a residential college and the kind of loyalty we feel to a
place like Yale as opposed to all other places.
That is to say,
Paula Marcus understands justice is kind of a kind of patriotic sentiment that
citizens of one city or one Polis feel for one another in opposition to all
other places.
Justice,
his devotion to one's own and one's own is the good for Palo Marcus.
Okay.
One's own is the just,
but Socrates challenges Paula mark this on the grounds that loyalty to a group,
any group,
uh,
cannot be a virtue in itself.
And he trips Paula Marcus up with a very,
uh,
in many ways,
familiar Socratic argument.
Do we ever make mistakes?
He Asks Paula Marcus isn't the distinction between friend and enemy based on a
kind of knowledge on a perception of who is your friend and who,
who is your enemy?
Have we ever mistaken friend for enemy?
The answer seems to be,
of course we have.
We,
we all know people who we thought to be our friends,
but we found out,
uh,
you know,
that they were talking behind our back story that they were operating to deceive
us or in some way or another.
Of course it happens.
It's happened to everyone.
So how can we say that justice means helping friends in harming enemies.
Socrates asks when we may not even be sure who our friends and our enemies are
really are.
Why should citizens of one state namely one's own,
if any moral priority over the citizens of another state when again,
we don't know them and we may well be mistaken in our assumption that they are
enemies or,
or friends isn't,
in other words,
an such an unreflective attachment to one's own bound to result in an injustice
to others.
Uh,
Socrates seems to be asking Palamara this once again,
in many ways we see Socrates dissolving the bonds of the familiar.
Uh,
it no other point in the republic I think do we see so clearly the tension
between philosophical reflectiveness on the one hand and the sense of
camaraderie,
mutuality and just spree decor necessary for political life on the other
Socrates seems to dissolve those bonds of familiarity,
loyalty and attachment that we all have by saying to Paula markets,
how do we know,
how do we really know a distinction between friend and enemy?
But Marcus seems to believe that a city can survive only with a vivid sense of
what it is,
of what we might say,
what it stands for,
and an equally vivid sense of what it is not and who are its enemies.
Isn't this essential for the survival of any stage of any city?
Uh,
to know who it's friends and enemies are,
uh,
who has challenges?
Arch Socrates's disillusion of that very framework,
uh,
challenges.
It seems to me the very possibility of political life by questioning the
question or the distinction between friend and enemy.
Although Paula Marcus like has father is reduced to silence.
It is,
it is notable that his argument is not defeated later in the republic.
You will see not,
not that much later,
even Socrates will argue that the best city may be characterized by peace and
harmony at home,
but this will never be so for relations between states.
Uh,
this is why even the best city even clipless will require,
as he spends a great deal of time discussing,
will require a warrior class,
a class of what he calls auxiliaries or auxiliaries war.
And the preparation for war is an intrinsic part of even the most just city.
Even the platonic just city.
We'll have to cultivate a warrior's citizens,
uh,
who are prepared to risk life in battle for the sake of their own city.
So in many ways it seems that Paula Marcus's argument why don't apparently
refuted in book one is rehabilitated and re,
uh,
re-emerges in its own way later in the dialogue.
And we might want to think about this because it is an argument that is very
important to a contemporary or 20th century important 20th century political
theorist by the name of Schmidt.
Uh,
who made the distinction between what he called the friend and the enemy,
right?
You remember the central to his understanding of politics.
This is an argument,
uh,
that comes from Paula Marcus in book one of,
of the Republic Paula Marcus's dispatched in one way or another.
And this creates the opportunity for the longest and in many ways,
most memorable,
uh,
exchange in book one and perhaps even the republic as a whole.
The exchange with their Simica who represents a far more difficult challenge in
his own way than either of the first two speakers.
Uh,
in many ways because Thrasymachus could be seen as a Socrates is a alter ego in
some way.
He's sort of evil twin.
Uh,
he is,
uh,
how to put it.
He is the doctor Moriarity to,
uh,
Socrates is Sherlock Holmes.
Uh,
you know,
the evil doppelganger in some way through Simica says arrival of Socrates.
In many respects.
He is,
he also likes Socrates is a teacher.
Clearly he is an educator.
He claims to have a certain kind of knowledge of what justice is and claims to
be able to teach it to others.
Uh,
he,
he is a teaching,
uh,
kind of,
we will find out a kind of hard headed realism that expresses discussed at Paula
Marcus's talk about loyalty and friendship and the like a justice he asserts is
the,
is the interest of the stronger every polity,
uh,
of which we know is based upon a distinction between the rulers and the ruled
justice consists of the rules.
That is to say that are made for the Bennett made by and for the benefits of the
ruling class.
Justice is nothing more or less.
Right.
Then what benefits the rulers,
the rulers who determine the laws a of justice.
There's civicus is of course,
even for us today,
a familiar kind of person.
He is the intellectual.
He who enjoys bringing,
uh,
you might say the harsh and unremitting facts about human nature to light who
enjoys dispelling illusions and pretty beliefs.
Uh,
he's the one who probably would be the first to tell you there is no Santa
Claus.
Uh,
he is that he is that kind of a hard boiled,
real us.
No matter how much we may dislike him.
In some ways,
one has to admit also there,
there may be a grain if,
if not more than a grain of truth in what he seems to be saying.
And He,
what he seems to be saying is this,
uh,
we are beings who are first and foremost dominated by a desire for power.
This is what distinguishes a,
you might say the true man,
uh,
the real man from the,
the Alpha,
the Alpha Male,
uh,
you might say from the slave power and domination are all we truly care about.
And when we get later in this semester to Thomas Hobbes think re remember three
Simica.
So I'll just say that for now.
Remember Thrasymachus when we get to Hobbs,
power and domination are all we care about.
And what is true of individuals is also true for collective,
uh,
entities.
Collective nouns like states and cities.
Every polity seeks its own advantage against others making might say relations
between states,
uh,
a condition of unremitting war of all against all in the language.
If I can switch to the language of modern economics,
one could say that for through simic as politics is a zero sum game,
there are winners and there are losers.
And the more someone wins,
that means the more someone else will lose.
And the rules of justice are simply the law's set up by the winners of the game
to protect and to promote their own interests.
It didn't take Karl Marx to invent or to discover that insight that,
uh,
am I to the rules of justice are simply the rules of the ruling class that that
comes straight out of out of through civicus book one of the Republic.
Well,
how,
how to respond.
Uh,
and again,
Socrates challenges through [inaudible] with a variation of the argument that
he'd used against Paula Marcus.
That is to say,
do we ever make mistakes?
That is to say it is not self evident or it is not always intuitively obvious
what our interests are.
Uh,
if justice is truly in the interests of the stronger,
doesn't it,
that requires some kind of knowledge,
some kind of reflection,
uh,
on the part of those in power to know what is really and truly in their
interests.
People make mistakes and it is very possible to mistake,
uh,
to make a mistake about your own interests.
And of course,
[inaudible] has to acknowledge this.
Of course,
the rulers make mistakes and he tries to invent an argument that if a ruler
makes a mistake,
he's not really a true ruler.
The true ruler is the person who,
uh,
both acts on his own interests and of course knows what those interests are.
But the point that he admits is all in a sense that Socrates needs justice is
not power alone.
Justice requires knowledge.
Justice requires reflection.
And that is of course at the core of the famous Socratic thesis,
uh,
that all virtue is a form of knowledge.
All the virtues require knowledge and reflection,
uh,
at their basis.
But much of the exchange with through simic is turns on the of what kind of
knowledge justice involved with justice is a kind of knowledge if justice equal
self interest and self interest requires knowledge.
Well,
what kind of knowledge is that?
There's Simica contends that justice consists of the art of convincing people to
obey the rules that are really in the interests of others.
The interests of their rulers.
Justice,
in other words,
for [inaudible] is a kind of suckers game,
uh,
obeying the rules,
that really benefit others largely because we fear the consequences of
injustice.
Uh,
justice is really something only respected by the week,
uh,
who are fearful of the consequences of injustice.
Uh,
again,
the true,
uh,
the,
the true,
the true ruler in some ways is one.
There.
Civicus believes he has the courage to act unjustly for his own interests.
The true ruler he says is one who is like a shepherd with a flock,
but he rules not for the benefit of the flock,
but of course for his own interests,
the good,
uh,
of the shepherd justice,
like all,
uh,
knowledge is really,
a form again of self interest.
And so one can ask,
right is,
is through simic as wrong to believe this.
And I,
I realize I'm moving over this very quickly,
but it's through [inaudible] wrong to believe that,
uh,
Socrates wins the argument in book one with,
with a kind of,
you might even say sleight of hand.
Uh,
both he and through simic is believed that justice is a virtue.
But Socrates says,
what kind of virtue is it to deceive and fleece other people?
There's civicus is forced to admit that the just person a is a fool.
Uh,
Thrasymachus believes is a fool for obeying laws that are benefits that are not
beneficial to him or the best life Thrasymachus believes is doing maximum
injustice to others.
Doing whatever you like.
And with that realization,
we see a very dramatic moment in book one,
even in the book as a whole to civicus blushes.
He blushes when he begins to real or when he realized that he has,
he has been defending the claim.
Not that justice is a virtue,
but that justice,
uh,
is something that,
that is really a form of,
of,
of weakness.
Uh,
simic is himself seems to be embarrassed by his defense of the tyrannical life
of,
of the unjust life.
Uh,
the suggestion Plato seems to be making by making Chris [inaudible] has blush is
despite all of his tough talk,
right,
that he's not as as tough as he as he appears to be,
as he wants to think of,
of himself to being,
he's shamed by the fact,
uh,
that he has been defending injustice in the tyrannical way of life.
Uh,
and so it appears the three conversations and book one ends with uncertainty
about what justice is.
We have,
we have had three views of capitalists,
Paula Marcus and through [inaudible],
they have all been refuted or,
uh,
been refuted.
But no clear alternative seems to have emerged a,
certainly Socrates is not really proposed an alternative to [inaudible] in his
exchange with him.
He is only,
as it were forced through civicus to see that the logic of his ideas,
the logic of his argument that justice is in the interest of his stronger is a
defense of tyranny and as a defense of the unjust way of life.
So all of book one is really a kind of warmup for what follows a in the rest of
the book.
Uh,
we find out presumably what,
what justice is until then,
uh,
until that point we have no reason to really give up on our,
current,
uh,
existing ideas about what justice is.
And this is where the two most important figures of the republic begin to make
their voices heard.
Yeah.
Those are Glaucon in Edia,
Mantas Glaucon tell Socrates that he just sad.
He is dissatisfied with the reputation of [inaudible].
And so should we,
uh,
through Mckee,
through simic as has been shamed,
he has been forced to see the,
uh,
logic where the logic of his argument takes him.
But that is not the same thing as being refuted,
uh,
through [inaudible] has really,
as it turns out,
a kind of girly man,
uh,
who is,
ashamed to be seen defending the unjust life.
But why,
why should we be ashamed to praise injustice?
Uh,
Glaucon challenges.
Socrates is not enough to show that justice is wrong.
Glaucon says what we need is to hear why justice is good or more precisely to
hear justice praised for itself.
Okay.
Is there,
in your opinion,
Glaucon asks Socrates a kind of good that we would choose because we delight in
it for its own sake.
Three 58 a,
is there a kind of good that we delight in for its own sake?
And this is where the rubber hits the road.
Who is Glaucon?
Uh,
Glaucon and Eddie and Manchester are the brothers of Plato.
And other than their appearance in this book,
there is no historical record left about them,
but Plato has given us enough
in the first place.
They are young aristocrats and Glaucoma cones desire to hear justice praised for
its own sake indicates something about his scale of values.
It would be vulgar.
He believes to speak of justice or any virtue in terms of material rewards or
consequences.
He does not need to hear justice praised for its benefits.
Uh,
he's indifferent to the consequences.
Rather he claims that he wants to hear justice defended the way that no one has
ever defended it before.
The brothers desire to hear justice praised for itself alone and that seems to
be expressive of their own freedom from mercenary re motives and incentives.
It reveals to us something about their idealism and a certain kind of loftiness
of soul.
And certainly the brothers we find out are not slouches.
They are not slouches at all.
Although it is easy to remember that later in the dialogue,
most of their contributions seem to be of the form of yes.
Socrates,
no Socrates.
They seem to be rather passive.
Uh,
interlocutors there early challenges to Socrates show them to be potential
philosophers.
That is to say the kind of persons who might one day rule.
The city of the two Glaucon seems to be the superior.
He is described as the most courageous,
uh,
which in that context means the most manly,
the most virile.
And later Socrates admits that he is always been full of wonder.
It can nature of the two brothers and three 68 [inaudible] he cites a line of
poetry,
uh,
you remember written about them for their distinction in battle.
They have been in war,
they have been tested in war.
Obviously.
They are also,
and we see this from their relationship between one another and the way they
speak to one another.
They are also highly competitive super achievers.
Uh,
a little bit like,
uh,
some of you perhaps,
there is quite a bit of jousting between them,
uh,
that you need to be attentive to and each proposes to Socrates a test that he
will have to pass in order to prove the value of justice and the just life
Glaucon goes on to rehabilitate the argument of Thrasymachus,
uh,
in many ways,
in a more vivid and a more expressive way than through civicus did himself.
Glaucon tells a story.
You'll remember
a story that he modifies from the historian Heraclitus,
uh,
a story about a man named guide who possessed a magic ring that conferred on him
the power of invisibility.
Who is not wondered what we would do if we had this power,
the power of invisibility guide gs and P in glow cones,
retelling of the story guide just uses this ring to murder the king and to sleep
with his wife and to set himself up as king.
What would you do
if you had this power?
Yeah,
this power of this magic rain where you could commit any crime,
indulge any vice commit,
any outrage and be sure you could always get away with it.
Why?
If you could do that,
uh,
would you wish to be just at the same time or wish to be just instead of that
this is the challenge that Glaucon poses to Socrates.
Why would someone with absolute power and complete immunity to punishment,
why would they prefer justice to injustice?
Tell me that.
Socrates Glaucon asks,
if Justice truly is something praiseworthy for itself alone,
then Socrates should be able to provide an answer that will satisfy a glock
cones retelling of the story of guide you.
So that is certainly a very tall order.
And that is where the brother adding a mattress chimes in.
Eddie and Matt has says somewhat different set of concerns.
He has her justice praise his whole life from parents and from poets and from
other authorities.
But for the most part,
he has only heard justice praised again for the benefits justice confers both in
this life.
And the next honesty is the best policy.
Uh,
we hear,
we've heard capitalists,
a cunt being concerned about returning to others.
What you owe,
uh,
as a way of pleasing the gods in the afterlife.
And addie and matches rightly takes this kind of argument to be two main.
That justice is simply a virtue for the week,
the lame and the unadventurous.
Uh,
if you were only concerned with the consequences,
a real man does not fear the consequences of injustice,
rather adding a mantises concern and he gives a very revealing image of what he
takes justice to be is with an image of self guardianship or self control.
He tells us a three 67 a that each would be his own God.
In other words,
we should not care what people say about us,
but we should be prepared to develop qualities of self containment,
autonomy and independence from the influence that others can exercise over us.
How can I develop those qualities of self guardianship or self control?
He asks Socrates and who has not felt that way before the two brothers desire to
hear justice praised for itself Glau cone and to live freely and independently.
Eddie Mantas and that shows to some degree,
I think,
uh,
their own sense of alienation from their own society.
If I can put the case for them slightly.
Anachronistically these are two sons,
uh,
of the upper bourgeoisie who feel degraded by the mendacity and the hypocrisy of
the world they see around them in any way.
What,
what person with any sensitivity to greatness has not felt this way at one time
or another.
The two are open to persuasion to consider alternatives,
perhaps even radical alternatives to the society that has nurtured them.
They are,
to put it another way,
perhaps potential not only potential rulers and potential philosophers,
they may also be potential revolutionaries and the remainder of the book is
addressed to them.
And of course people like them.
With the speeches of Glaucon at Eddie and Mantis,
you might say the circle around Socrates is effectively closed.
He knows he will not be returning to Athens that evening.
Antique proposes.
Instead he proposes to the Doobie brothers and those listening to the
conversation,
a kind of thought experiment did.
He hopes will work magic on the to let us propose.
He says to watch a city coming into being in speech but is create a city in
speech,
it is easier.
He says to view justice,
uh,
not to view justice microscopically and an individual,
but rather let's view justice as it were through a magnifying glass.
Let's view justice in the large sense.
Let us view justice in a city in order to help us understand what it is in an
individual.
And this idea that the city is essentially analogous to the soul,
that the city is like the soul is the central metaphor around which the entire
republic is constructed.
It seems to be presented entirely innocuously no one in the dialogue objects to
it.
Yet everything else follows from this idea that the,
that the city,
the Polis is in certain essential respects,
like an individual,
like the soul of an individual.
What is Socrates trying to do here and what is that metaphor,
that central metaphor in what function does it serve within the work?
Okay.
To state the obvious,
uh,
Socrates introduces this analogy to help the brothers better understand what
justice is for an individual soul.
The governance of the soul.
Adding a mantises standard of self control,
uh,
must be like the governance of a city in some decisive respects.
But in what respects,
how was this city like a soul and in what respect is self governance?
The control of one's passions and appetites in what respect is self control.
Like the governance of a collective body.
Consider the following example.
When we say that so and so is typically American or typically to take Taiwanese
for example,
we mean that that person expresses certain traits of character and behavior that
are broadly representative and some way of the cross section of their
countrymen.
Is that,
is this a useful way to think,
uh,
more specifically,
what does it mean to say that an individual can be seen as magnified in his or
her country or that one's country is simply the collective expression of certain
individual traits of character?
That seems to be what Socrates is suggesting,
right?
Said what he's,
he's getting at.
One way of thinking about the metaphor of city and soul together is to think of
it as a particular kind of causal hypothesis,
uh,
about the formation of both individual character and political institutions.
And this reading of the city Seoul analogy as a kind of causal relation,
uh,
maintains the view that indeed that is individuals we both shape and determine
the character of our societies and that those societies in turn,
shape and determine individual character,
the city and soul analogy.
Could be seen then it's an attempt to understand how society's reproduce
themselves and how they shaped citizens who again,
in turn shaped the societies in which they inhabit.
Okay.
That seems to be one way of making sense of the city Seoul a hypothesis.
But it again,
it doesn't seem to answer the question.
In what way are cities and individuals alike to take the American case,
for example,
does it mean that something like,
uh,
the presidency,
the congress and just end the court,
uh,
can be discerned within the soul of every American citizen?
That would be absurd to think that obviously,
uh,
I mean,
I think it would be absurd.
Maybe,
maybe you want to argue it and we could have a discussion,
but,
uh,
it might mean that um,
American democracy or democracy of any kind,
uh,
helps to produce a particular kind of democratic soul.
Uh,
just like you might say,
the old regime and France,
the old aristocratic society existing before the revolution tended to produce a
very different kind of soul,
very different kind of individual.
Every regime will produce a distinctive kind of individual and this individual
will come to embody the dominant,
the dominant character traits of the particular regime.
The remainder of the republic is again devoted to crafting a regime that will
produce a distinctive kind of human character.
And that of course is why the book is a utopia.
There has never been a regime in history.
It was so single mindedly devoted to the end of producing that rarest and most
difficult species of humanity called simply philosopher.
Okay,
so sitting in soul.
That leads to our next topic that I want to pursue for the,
for the remainder of the class,
the reform of poetry and the arts.
Socrates city in speech proceeds through stages.
The first stage proposed by adding a Mantis is the simple city what he calls the
city of most necessity.
That is a city limited to the satisfaction of certain basic needs,
the primitive or simple city,
the simplicity of utmost necessity.
Again,
it expresses the nature of adding a mantises own soul.
There was a kind of noble simplicity in him that treats subjects as bodies or
creatures of limited appetites.
The simple city is little more than a combination of households designed for
this sake of securing one's existence.
And at this point,
and you can hear his brother,
uh,
chastising him at this point,
Glaucon retorts that it seems as if his bro,
it seems as if adding a man has,
has created a city only fit four pigs,
uh,
city of pigs.
Are we only such that we want to feed it a common trough?
Uh,
is there nothing more to,
to politics and that,
and Glaucon says,
where are the luxuries?
Where are the relishes?
He asks,
where are the things that make up a city and to hear to Glaucon city expresses
his own tastes and his own soul.
The warlike Glau cone would preside over what Socrates calls a feverish city,
one that institutionalizes honors competitions and above all war,
if adding a mattress again expresses the appetitive part of the soul.
Glaucon cone represents that quality that Plato calls spiritedness or through
most in Greek.
Spiritedness is this central psychological quality of the republic.
The entire thrust of the book is devoted to the taming of spiritedness and to
the control of spiritedness spirited is spiritedness is that quality of soul
that is most closely associated with the desire,
desires for honors,
fame and prestige is a higher order,
psychological quality.
It is what's dis seeks distinction,
the desire to be first in the race of life and lead us to seek to dominate
others.
We all know people have this sword,
do we not?
And we all to some degree embodied this quality in ourselves.
It is the quality that we associate with being a kind of Alpha personality.
Uh,
this is the issue for Socrates.
How to channel this wild and untamed passion of spirit or heart.
How to channel this to some kind of common good.
Can it be done?
How can we begin the domestication of the spirited Glaucon?
The rest of the book is to some degree about taming glow,
whether asking the question whether Glau cone can be tamed.
And it is here that Socrates turns to his first and perhaps even his most
controversial proposal for the establishment of the just city.
The creation of the just city can only begin,
he says with the control of music,
poetry,
and the arts.
And this is where Plato's image,
uh,
as an educator derives.
Yeah.
The first order of business for the founder of a city,
any city is the oversight of education and his proposals for the reform of
poetry,
especially Homeric poetry represent clearly a radical departure from Greek
educational practices and beliefs.
Why is this so important for Socrates?
Ask yourself if you were founding a city,
uh,
where would you begin?
Uh,
Socrates belief or his argument seems to be something like this.
it is from the poets and I mean that in the broadest sense of the term myth
makers,
storytellers,
artists,
musicians.
Today we might say a film producers and television,
Film and television producers.
It is from these people that we receive our earliest and most vivid impressions
of heroes and villains,
gods and the afterlife.
These stories,
the stories we hear from earliest childhood on shape us in some very meaningful
sense for the rest of our lives and the Homeric epics or of course for the
Greeks,
what the Bible was for us maybe even is in some communities the names of
Achilles,
Priam,
Hector,
Odysseus Ajax.
These would have been just as familiar and important to the contemporaries of
Plato is the names of Abraham,
Isaac,
Joshua,
and Jesus are for us
Plato's critique of how America poetry in the republic is twofold.
It is both theological and political.
Maybe you might even say following Spinosa that this is the car of spin of,
of Plato's theological political,
a treatise here.
Uh,
the theological critique is that homer simply depicts the gods as false,
as fickle and in constant,
he presents them as beings who are unworthy of our worship.
Uh,
more importantly,
the Homeric heroes are said to be bad role models for those who follow them.
They are shown to be intemperate insects,
overly fond of money into these vices,
Socrates ads,
cruelty and disregard for the dead bodies of the opponents of one's opponents.
The Homeric heroes are ignorant and passionate men full of blind anger and
desire for retribution.
How could such figures possibly serve as good role models for citizens of a bay
adjust city?
And Socrates answer is of course the purgation of poetry and the arts in books
two and three.
He wants to deprive poets of their power to enchant and something Socrates
admits in the 10th Book of the Republic to which he,
he himself has been highly susceptible to the enchanted meant,
uh,
of the poets.
How we need to deprive again,
the poets,
the,
uh,
the song makers,
the lyricists,
the musicians,
the myth makers,
the storytellers,
all of them the power to enchant us,
uh,
and in place of the pedagogical power of poetry,
Socrates proposes to install philosophy in its place.
As a result,
the poets,
we'll have to be expelled from the city.
Imagine that Sophocles,
there'll be expelled from the justice city,
uh,
that Socrates wants to create.
This always raises the question that you will discuss in your section whether or
not Socrates is censorship of poetry and the arts is an indication of his
totalitarian impulses.
This is the part of the republic most likely to call up our own first amendment
instincts.
Uh,
who are you?
Socrates.
We are inclined to ask to tell us what we can read here and listened to.
And furthermore,
uh,
Socrates seems to be saying not that the color Lippolis will have no poetry and
music.
It will simply be Socratic poetry and music.
And here's another question which you will no doubt be concerned to discuss.
Namely what would such socratically purified music and poetry look like?
What would it sound like?
I don't know that I have an answer to this,
but perhaps the republic as a whole is itself a piece of this Socratic poetry
that will substitute for the Homeric kind.
But it's important to remember that,
uh,
the question of education and the question of the reform and censorship and
control of poetry is introduced in the context of taming the warlike passions of
Glau cone and others like him.
The question of censorship and the telling of lies is introduced.
In other words,
as a question of military necessity,
controlling the guards or the auxiliary is of the city.
It's warrior class.
Nothing is said here about the education of farmers,
artisans,
merchants,
laborers,
the economic class maybe just speak bluntly.
Socrates just doesn't care that much about them.
It's okay what they listened to.
Uh,
nor has anything really been said up to this point about the education of the
philosopher is interest here is in the creation of a tight in highly disciplined
cadre of young warriors who will protect the city much as watchdogs protect
their own home.
That is to say recall and Paula Marcus,
those who are good to friends and bark and growl at strangers.
Such individuals will substitute their own desires and pleasures to the group,
uh,
and live a life by a strict code of honor.
We have to ask our Socrates,
is proposals unrealistic?
Are they undesirable or are,
are they desirable?
Uh,
they are not undesirable.
If you believe as he does that even the best city must provide provisions for
war and therefore a warriors life.
A soldier's life will require harsh privation in terms of material,
awards and benefits,
as well as a willingness to sacrifice for others.
It would seem far from being unrealistic.
Uh,
Socrates engages what we might call maybe a kind of Socratic realism.
Far more unrealistic would be the belief of those who argue.
And I'm thinking here of names like Emmanuel,
Kant and others from the 18th and 19th century,
that one day we can abolish war altogether and therefore abolish the passions
that give rise to conflict and war.
So far,
Plato believes is the passionate or spirited aspect of human nature remains
strong.
So long will it be necessary to educate the warriors of society who defended?
So on that,
I'm going to end today and next time we will talk about justice,
the philosophers and Plato's discovery of America.